every single time i've been like a guest
at a con something
has gone like horribly wrong with like
my flight my hotel
really yeah yeah i think i've been
pretty lucky i've had like a few cons
where it was like
horrible yeah but a lot of the times
like especially the smaller cons i have
more fun at a smaller conference yeah
yeah if i get there yeah like one time
uh
this con uh booked me like like months
in advance and i don't think they'd ever
had an international guest so i told
them like hey you should like book
flights soon because like
you're in the middle of nowhere in the
u.s it's like in indiana right right
i was like you need to book flights
because like they don't happen a lot
from the uk
and they didn't until like one week
before and then i had to go on like a 35
hour flight path 35 yeah well it should
have been uh like a
14 at most right yeah that was the
cheapest friday
that was the cheapest one and i i asked
i asked them i was like how much was the
one
the other one that was like i think it
was like 12 hours still long
yeah light path and they were like oh it
was 150 bucks more and i'm like are you
kidding me
are you kidding me why did you agree to
this well i already signed the contract
before that because they said they were
going to buy the flights and i thought
they wouldn't do that to me
that's surreal that's a real moment
there they wouldn't they wouldn't expect
me to turn up on my flight and then
immediately do a panel within 30 minutes
of arriving
and they did they expected me to do that
i've done that before so
they and the worst part is they booked
me a hotel the night before that i
missed because of the 35 hour flight
path and i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure that hotel room cost
more than 150 dollars
so [ __ ] you that con
every con is in in indiana now it's just
like sweating
i've had a lot of the worst experiences
in that one car
of all states i don't know why i go
through a lot of cons in indiana for
some reason
it's i went to one in indiana which was
uh indie popcorn and
that one was actually quite fun yeah i
had a lot of fun with that but that one
one
wasn't really well first it wasn't
really like an anime convention it was
more like a youtuber convention
so i think they were a lot more used to
getting all sorts of overseas guests
yeah yeah
was was your agent doing all of that for
you when the cons or was it
you were you negotiating with them uh at
axe i was just an industry guest so i
was just
at a booth right other people but at a
smaller con i was a guest so
i got somebody from the con with me all
the time right
oh you got a handler yeah yeah yeah yeah
cause i feel like because i spoke
english they were just like left me to
my own device and they were like [ __ ] it
just turn up
just i just we just expect you to be
here no i remember my first
time like being a proper guest at a
convention i think was like crunchyroll
expo
because i had been guests before but i
remember that my first experience at
quantual expo they gave me a handler and
had no experience
like what i do like like he would just
follow
me around and i would just i would just
feel so awkward i would just be like
could you not i literally had to ask him
to like okay
can you just chill like i i'm not like
because i've heard a lot of horror
stories
i get it now but back then it was my
first experience so i'm just like dude
can you just
can you just leave me alone i'm i'm all
good i don't need any help i'm just i'm
just walking around the contour
every time i wanted to go to the
bathroom because they had to follow me
and i'm sorry i have a small
brother sorry
yeah so no i'm just very used to being
left my own devices as well because
i think it's a very british thing as
well you're like i don't want someone
helping me i can do it on my own
i mean like i think it's because i've
had like kind of my fair share of like
good
really good handlers and just really
useless handlers yeah
then like i i'm a little bit better to
like i know how to use my handler now
right like i know
i know that's what i'm saying
i don't know
you know what i mean like like you know
i'm going to min max this [ __ ]
joey turns up and he just gives him like
a like a [ __ ] 10
page survey fill this out i need to know
where is my don perry
on when the moment i land come on guys
can i speak to you
i'm like this is [ __ ] joey's had
really good experiences and i i feel
like at least half of my like
conventions that weren't like ax had
like something massive
it's really weird like you know you hear
a lot of like horror stories about ax
from a lot of different people i don't
think i've had like a
like a horrible experience at ax no i've
i think but i think it's also because
yeah but i think it's also because like
my schedule i purposely
fill up my schedule yeah with as much
[ __ ] to do
so that i don't leave enough room for
error right because like a lot of people
are just like i'm gonna space everything
out
and then you know just give myself some
time in between each thing but i'm just
like no that's where the horror happens
right
it's the in-between part where you're
just kind of left on your own you're
like
well i guess i'll go to the convention
hall now and then horrible things happen
at the convention hall right
ax has always been like the super super
busy convention
it's everyone's always busy everyone's
always doing something like
what is your schedule like an ax is it i
was like signing
uh and they give in the first year
they gave me like a 30 minutes break
yeah
myself just in a bathroom store i would
just
be myself i just want to take a rest but
i couldn't take a rest
i didn't want anyone to see me without a
wig okay
the car was so unthinkable how could you
taking off a wig no no no disgusting i
just kept myself confining the store
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry and i took
aspirin like every single
oh my god i mean yeah i guess if you
have like a wig cap that's just like
stretching your head right now like at
some point i wanted like a stronger mess
or like a could you buy something and i
like in in the state like i'm sure they
got like stronger rocks
give me that give me that because i've
never cosplayed before
um and part of the reason is it feels
like
at a convention wearing a cosplay is
just a lot of
effort and work to just to keep it
intact right
yeah i i cosplayed once and that was at
ax
and i cosplayed as gintoki from gingkam
and i chose gintoki because not only
because i like gin doki as a character
but also because like his stuff is kind
of light right it's like it's a lot more
breathable it's not like i'm wearing
a full suit of armor right so i'm just
like okay it's really hot
this is a little bit breathable i didn't
take into account that i'd be wearing
a massive [ __ ] white wig
yeah yeah and because this part got just
so
hot yeah it completely just negated
my the free-flowing clothes that i was
wearing so i'm just like
i was i remember i was in the middle of
a signing i'm just like i'm sorry i
can't i just took it off
i'm sorry [ __ ] the hair man i can't do
it yourself yeah i was like i don't care
anymore i'm just gonna take it off it's
so hot in here
yeah i see like some people in eggs like
turning rocking up in like a full
guts armor or something i'm like how the
[ __ ] are you doing
it's like 33 degrees celsius here right
now because if you just restrict all
your pores
you can't sweat it can't come out
you just can't come out right you're
impressive yeah yeah that's why i wore a
virgin killer sweater at ax one time
oh yeah yeah i mean that's that's
breathable right yeah that's very
what i mean is that why is that why you
like cosplaying as girls because it's no
no no it's dude i love skirts because
like you're laughing
you feel like free flow dude i feel like
i can stretch like my full stretch you
know what i mean
but you didn't get stopped by a security
you're like no
in in la it's normal like i i just where
anything goes in la
especially around ax you know i remember
i got i got in the uber and it was just
a guy
and at the moment i sat in he was like
you going to the la convention center
and i was like yep yeah